uh for this from the sun it says
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg has
announced that it's uh ray-ban smart
glasses will be the company's next
product to launch
zuckerberg made the comment during
facebook's second quarter earnings call
facebook has
planned to launch its smart classes as
its next product he said looking ahead
here the next product release will be
the launch of our
first smart glasses from rayban in
partnership with
isilor laxatica whatever that is
uh the ceo didn't add much more than
other than that other than saying the
glasses will let the wearers do some
pretty neat things
what do we know about facebook smart
glasses so far facebook has big plans
for smart glasses but the first pair
won't be classified as an augmented
reality product
um and
as far as what it what as far as what
exactly they'll do
uh there's still not a lot no no but
you know these are elections so
electronic device you're gonna wear on
your head
potentially giving facebook the ability
to record
everything you do and say
and there's a big privacy thing there um
but you know
here's what frustrates me
you ask almost anyone in america
whether or not they value their privacy
and whether their privacy rights are
important to them
all of them will say yes
one of the most important things in fact
based on our words
and the values and our values as we
present them
we value privacy more than anyone else
ever has in history we certainly talk
about it a lot more
and yet you know that these facebook
glasses are going to come out
and they'll sell like hotcakes
millions of people who otherwise would
say i really
i have a right to privacy i care so much
about my privacy
then facebook says oh here are some
glasses where i'm on your head we'll
record everything you do and say
oh yes please
this is always that that tension where
we we say we value our privacy
and yet all of us willingly sacrifice
so much of it every single day as a
matter of course
uh and many of us going much further
than that
wearing facebook glasses i think would
be a pretty extreme
way to sacrifice your own privacy listen
hit that subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated